when we started to go after greg's dream
of being a professional longboarder life
changed a lot
you're out with your father you're just
out there having fun like nothing really
beats that like chasing after the same
dream
i think that's the best part about it
for sure
this is mike paprovsky he's my father he
does downhill skateboarding along with
street illusion
this is greg paprovsky he's from golden
colorado he's a downhill
downhill longboarding is basically going
down the hill as fast as you can
street luge is very similar to
longboarding except you lay down
greg still is the youngest to have
competed at the pikes peak downhill race
here in colorado springs the fastest
i've gone today is 70 miles an hour but
that's that's about it
2011
my ex and i were going through divorce
it was a big adjustment for greg he was
lashing out physically and having
problems in school
i needed to try to motivate him get him
on the right track i told him if you get
your stuff together in school we can go
after any dream you want to
i decided i want to pursue longboarding
because it put me in the zone and made
me forget about all the negative things
that were happening in my life at the
time
so i bought him a leather suit for
christmas that year and and our first
year on the scene we traveled to canada
new york washington california
we were at the ohio gravity games
we rode the free bus to within five
miles of the event and then we lugged
all of our luggage down there it started
raining on us we had a two-man tent
that's all we had and as we were cuddled
up in that tent with all our gear and
everything
gregory
said to me he goes dad you never told me
the dream was gonna be easy
and it it was at that point i knew this
kid's got it he understands like he gets
it just being able to be at the very
lowest with my father and the very
highest we know that we can tough out
anything together and that we can we can
make it
i've seen greg grow a lot since we
started skateboarding a lot of people
look at something and think oh you can't
can't do that
greg looks at it and says how am i gonna
do that
if people could understand
that
this is the kin to the scariest thing
you've ever done
then they'll start to understand why
we're so addicted to it
when i put the goggles on the first
thing i'm doing is trying to calm
it
down
puts you inside the drone you
just forget where you are
i'm conrad miller also known as ferrari
and i'm a drone racer
i started in september 2014 and that was
like
the ground floor
all the activities i've partaken in
motorcycles and flying drones are on the
same level in terms of intensity
it's cool when you have a hobby and you
can do it and you love it but when you
can share it with your kids i mean
that's just you know that's just like
what it's all about i think okay so
props are good
flying and racing with sorel
has just been a pure joy he's a good kid
and he's a talented kid and i think it
comes easy to take any kid like that
because they don't feel the pressure
that adults do
good landing
coming in hot
this is harder than
anything else i've done and it's because
when you're when your nerves go your
fine motor skills go kids don't care
they're having fun
and they just learn much faster
the course in la is at the hawthorne
mall which is abandoned it's been
abandoned since the 80s i believe and it
looks like a place where you would go if
there was a zombie apocalypse
when i go into races i feel like i put
a lot of pressure on myself to win you
know i want all of my
practice and all of my
time flying to show up or something
i was flying fine i wasn't nervous but i
was just a little too high and crashed
you like almost hit the ceiling you're
like
everybody is just working really hard to
be the best at it
and it's just going to get tougher and
tougher i take that 180 good yeah you
did flying with swell now it kind of
gives me an opportunity to look at it
from a different perspective because i
can coach him ready
he's aware enough to know that he gets
to do these things that most kids don't
get to do he's flying a drone which is
this groundbreaking thing
we hate each other you hit me what are
you talking about we hit each other you
know as parents we don't always feel
like we do enough i brought him into
drone racing and he knows he's lucky and
he knows he's fortunate yeah kiddo
you're going pretty quick and you know
he's just he's grateful for everything
that he gets
we get to carry down knowledge through
our bloodline through the generations
six to three years of my family's work
has led to this moment of this person
enjoying his greato and it's the best
feeling in the world
what makes greato greato
is the sound and the story
my family's been here since 1911 we're
still in the same building since 1918.
we were a fruit store
now we're an audio company
the feedback we get from people is
there's a greater signature sound so we
just might be trained to
keep that tradition going
my uncle
he started out making phonograph
cartridges you'd make a few on his
kitchen table go out sell them come back
make a few more go out sell them
when the production exceeded the size of
his kitchen table he went around the
corner closed up grado fruit
and
opened up greater laboratories and now
we're here
it was said he had golden ears
he trained me how to listen and what to
listen for
growing up here was interesting i'd see
them building headphones and i would try
but i would just smash pieces together
and i would just
play with them and think i was building
a headphone but i was probably just
breaking stuff
jonathan he is kind of like our conduit
to the world i also just like a young
face brought to the company
in the seventh or eighth grade i had a
career day to go to we had to dress up
as what we wanted to be when we grew up
and i came in dressed as my dad which
was jeans in a t-shirt and with
headphones on and i was like i'm going
to be my dad and i'm going to do all
this stuff
i mean it's just like when i kind of
took over from my uncle
we've gone through two generations and
now the third generation is being primed
to take over
foreign
a
foreign
a
my mom is an amazing person
and rosario vargas are a mother and
daughter separated by a border
one living in san diego and the other in
mexico
i came from mexico 2006 because i wanted
to get another opportunity for my kids
when
i don't have the permission to cross the
border the line
from the last year and a half i see my
mom to the fence
at the site of a bi-national park in san
diego the u.s border patrol allows
families to meet
on the weekends loved ones enter the
park and walk directly up to the border
a steel fence
this gives families on both sides a rare
opportunity to see
you know
you're gonna see your mom you're gonna
see your family but
the fans only have a tiny hose
and my mom sometimes
put
the finger in the tiny hole just a
little touch it just touch it or
sometimes i give you a kiss
of himself
on april 30th for the third time ever
authorities agreed to open the door
allowing select families a brief moment
to embrace
each of them will only have three
minutes
they get
right now i feel so happy because i'm
waiting i'm waiting so much this moment
for the third time ever we have the
opportunity to have this door open
i feel
incredible
she was so happy
she was so sweet with me she told me i
love you mommy i love you so much i love
you i love you
you